The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
HARI BALAKRISHNAN: OK.
So today, we're going
to continue talking
about multi-hop networks.
And in particular,
I'm going to talk
about a fairly fundamental
problem in multi-hop networks
called network routing.
And that's the topic for today
and through most of, half of,
next week.
And today, this week,
we'll talk about network
routing in networks where
there are no failures.
So in real networks,
of course, things fail.
Packets get dropped.
Nodes may fail.
Switches may fail.
Links may fail.
We'll just worry about
the case when there
are no failures for this week.
Next week, we'll add
some more complexity
and talk about how we
deal with failures.
So the abstract problem
is pretty simple.
You have a set of
nodes in the network.
And there's some
network topology.
And every source
in the network--
you have sources, and
you have destinations,
nodes in the network.
And they wish to send
packets to each other.
And we're going to
decompose this problem,
these endpoints,
which actually want
to communicate with each other,
as we've already talked about,
do so by sending
packets via switches.
And the problem we're
going to worry about
is what happens inside the
network in these switches.
The switches solve
the following problem.
If things work correctly
and if things work well,
when a switch receives a
packet with a destination
address specifying
that that packet has
to be sent to a particular named
destination to the network,
the switch figures out
how to ship that packet.
It figures out whether
to send it along--
I need a better--
here.
This switch, for
example, figures out
whether a package should go
along that link, or this link,
or this link, or this
link, or that link,
given any package
that it receives.
And every switch in the
network performs this task.
Now, when a switch gets
a packet and the packet
has a destination address
in it, what the switch does
is some sort of a lookup.
It looks up that destination
in some sort of a table.
And that table maintains
information about which
of the links to use
in sending that packet
toward the destination.
And this step is
called forwarding.
Packets are forwarded
by switches.
Technically, packets
aren't routed.
Everybody says packet
routing, and I say it, too.
But it's important to realize
packets aren't routed.
Packets are forwarded.
The forwarding process is pretty
straightforward at slow speeds.
You get a packet.
You take the destination.
You look up that
packet in a table.
And that table tells you what
you do with the packet, which
link to use.
Routing is the problem
that the switches solve
of constructing these tables.
So forwarding is simply
lookup in a table.
And the table is called
the routing table.
Sometimes it's also called
the forwarding table.
And there's a technical
difference between them that's
not that important for us.
So forwarding is the process
of looking up the destination
in the routing table.
Routing is the
distributed process,
the algorithm that's
used or the protocol
that's used, to build
up these routing tables.
So it's the
construction process,
how to construct
these routing tables
at each switch in the network.
That's done in the background.
That's usually done in software.
Switches at high speeds involve
a fair amount of hardware.
Routing itself is
usually done in software.
And so a typical switch has
a lot of different processing
elements in it.
A lot of those
processing elements
are high speed
hardware that deals
with the process of forwarding.
And then you have software
sitting on the side
where all of the complexity is.
And all that complexity
deals with all sorts
of complicated rules that
you have to come up with
in order to decide how to
construct these routing tables.
And we're going to talk about
the world's simplest networks
today.
And you'll find that
even that's reasonably
sophisticated and complicated.
So just for
concreteness, an example
of a picture of a
topology is like this.
And for reasons that
will become apparent
as we talk this through,
we'll model the network
as a set of nodes
and a set of links.
And so far, there's
nothing new about this.
But we'll model links
as having a cost.
And this cost might reflect, for
example, the delay or latency
to send a packet
along that link.
The cost might reflect
the real dollar cost
of shipping data along links.
Internet service providers
might charge different amounts
of money for different
types of data, for example.
Or the cost might just reflect
your own internal preferences
as to which links
you might prefer
based on whatever concerns.
Maybe some links are slow,
and some links are fast.
Maybe there are higher speed
links, lower speed links, that
cost more or less, et cetera.
So these costs are
abstract numbers.
And we'll just assume that
we're interested in finding
minimum cost paths between
senders and receivers.
So every switch
solves the problem
of finding the minimum cost
path to a destination where
the cost along a path is
simply the sum of the costs
along the links on that path.
This is just standard
shortest path routing.
We'll use shortest
path even though we
don't mean literally the
shortest number of hops,
but the minimum cost path.
And where that distinction is
important between the number
of hops and the cost, et
cetera, we'll clarify.
So the routing table
looks something like this.
In fact, it looks like this.
There's destination.
Every switch has this.
So this is an example of
a routing table at node
B. Node B maintains all the
destinations in the network.
And we're dealing with small
networks so far in our class.
So we'll just assume that
every node in the network
has a unique name
or a unique address,
and that the routing
tables contain
an entry for every
destination in the network.
So the routing table
has three columns.
It's a database
with three columns.
And every switch in
the network or a node--
I'm going to use the word node
and switch interchangeably.
Every switch or
node in the network
has one of these if the
network is working correctly.
So if the routing
protocol does its job,
every node comes up with its
own version of this table.
There is a destination.
There is the link
you need to use
that is the next hop, if you get
a packet to this destination,
what link would you
use, and a cost.
So in this table,
if node B or switch
B received a packet
destined for destination A,
it would use link L1.
Each link is named locally.
So B would have its
own L0, L2, and L1.
You know, your own computer
has a bunch of links.
I don't know what the
command is in Windows,
but in all other sensible
platforms, if you do IF Config,
you can get it.
I think it's called IP
config on a Windows.
But you can actually
see a list of links.
So switches have many,
many, many links.
And so you'll find, for
example, for destination A
you use link L1.
The cost is 18.
In fact, you'll see here that,
when B receives a packet for A,
it doesn't use the direct link
because the direct link has
a cost of 19, whereas
going through L1,
this link has a cost of 11.
And if B believes that the
path toward A along this link
has a cost of 11 plus 7 is
18, that's what it thinks.
And, therefore, it
would use that link.
OK?
It's very simple.
Now, routing is the
process by which
these different nodes
talk to each other
and build up these tables.
When I say a route to a
destination, I mean this.
I mean the route to a
destination at a switch
or at a node is the link
that that destination would
use to send packets
to the destination.
This is important
technically for us.
Because, otherwise, we
will get all tangled up
getting confused between
routes and paths.
OK.
For the purposes
of our discussion,
a route is the next
hop link, is the link
that you're going to use
to get to the destination.
The path is a sequence of links.
So I don't want people telling
me that the route from B to E
is whatever, is BCE.
I'd like people to tell me
that the route at node B
to destination E is L1.
Or if you wish to
be clear, you can
say, it's link L1 which
takes it to next hop
C. The path from B
to E might BCE, OK?
All right, so that's what
the routing table structure
looks like.
And we're interested
in minimum cost paths
to go from places to places.
So normally, traditionally,
we sit around
and try to now dive
into protocols.
But I think here what
we're going to do
is since our notes are all
so nice and written up,
I actually don't have to tell
you everything that's there.
So what we're
actually going to do
is something we call
the routing game, which
is an experiment in
social networking.
What it means is that
each of you or some of you
will act as nodes and
start computing routes
to different destinations.
OK, so that's what this
game is going to be.
So what I have in my hand
is 40 slips of paper.
And I hope there are 40 people
here, 40 slips of paper.
And each of these slips of
paper has some information
that looks like this.
It says you are node X, and
you're connected to nodes Y, Z,
W, et cetera, OK?
And there's a set of rules that
I will go through in a minute.
First of all, these were
all in perfect order.
So I need to shuffle them a few
times carefully without losing
them.
I think Perci Diaconis,
the famous probabilist,
said that you've got
to do this seven times.
Maybe this is close to seven.
OK.
So what I'm going to do is
I'm going to pass this around.
There's no bag here.
The bag's cumbersome.
So what I'd like you
to do-- actually,
I'll put it in the envelope
and pass it around.
Just kind of close
your eyes or something.
Don't look at the number.
And just pick one up.
And don't look at it
until I tell you, OK?
So we'll start here and
just pass it around.
I'd like 40 different
people to have them.
You don't have to feel
compelled to take it, but just
pass it around.
And try to do it
quickly because I'd
like that to happen faster than
the time it's going to take
for us to compute these routes.
So why don't you just pick
one sheet of paper up and just
pass it around, please?
OK, so I picked 7 minutes.
It sometimes works a
little faster than 7.
The best that the class has
done is about 5 minutes.
Last time, they did it very
quickly, but they got it wrong.
So I don't think that counts.
But I've been told
that they've tried
this experiment at Berkeley.
It's taken usually
more than 7 minutes.
And I figure MIT
students are smarter.
So let's see if you can do
it faster than 7 minutes.
Now, your job is to find
a path from a source
node to a destination node
as quickly as possible, OK?
And I mean, as a
bonus, if you actually
find the path with the
minimum number of hops, that's
even better, but
we'll take any path.
Now, there's some rules here.
Now, there are some rules here.
So you may not
actually kind of get up
and run around and try to do
things that a normal network
switch wouldn't do.
So you're allowed to
stay in one place.
And what you're
actually allowed to do
is you're not allowed to
pass your sheet of paper
to other people because you
have information about yourself.
And that piece tells you
who your neighbors are,
the numbers of your neighbors.
So you can't actually kind
of send your piece of paper
to other nodes.
That's not allowed.
And don't let people copy
what's on your sheet of paper.
Now, here's some
things you can do.
You can read them.
Ask your friends for advice.
You can shout to
other participants.
We're allowing you
to yell and scream,
but do so in a way that's
somewhat civilized.
And you can wish that
you didn't pick up a slip
or pick up a slip or whatever.
But try to act generally--
I mean, this class is recorded.
So you know, what you
say might be heard.
Now, if you get a slip,
there's some ground rules.
You can't cheat.
We're not dealing
with security here
where a node that's 17
and connected to 27 and 29
tells people that it's 14.
I mean, you don't want that.
It's hard enough to do
when you tell the truth.
So don't cheat.
There's probably
a variant of this
we can come up with where
some fraction of the nodes
are adversarial and one can't
see if this stuff even works.
But right now, don't cheat.
If you've got a
slip, you kind of
have to really try to
participate in whatever
protocol you come up with.
And this experiment has no
human subjects approval.
OK.
So who has the envelope?
Is it empty?
Oh my goodness, it's
7 minutes already.
Let's move it around.
OK.
When the envelope gets empty,
we can start this thing.
So we should try
to move it along.
Is everyone clear on the rules?
What you're trying to do is to
find a path between the source
node, which was numbered
1, and the destination
node that was numbered 40.
The source and the destination
know who they each are.
And then we're
just going to wait.
This is the easiest
lecture to prepare
for because I just have to
keep quiet for a few minutes.
OK.
And if things don't work
out or things don't work,
whatever it is, I'm
assuming that you'll
come up with some variant of
a reasonable routing protocol.
And odds are, it'll
be a variant of one
of the ones we're
going to study.
You know, the gentleman
here who suggested
something was a reasonable
idea, which is you
go and you pick one
neighbor and you go through.
But you get stuck in a
loop, and then the idea
is you come back
to where you start.
And then you go
through the next.
And that principle
could work, but you
got to remember a lot of stuff
and tends to make mistakes.
And in fact, this
was an easy network
where every node had one,
two, or three neighbors.
I mean, there's a few with
more, but most of them
had a small number of neighbors.
What you guys were
going after was
a sort of better plan,
which everybody yells out
their neighbors.
And then they yell out their
neighbors and their neighbors
and so forth.
And that particular protocol
has a nice name to it.
It's called link-state routing,
where you broadcast and flood
your own neighbor
information, OK?
That's the second of the two
protocols we're going to study.
What you were trying to go
after was link-state routing.
Now, the first protocol
we're going to study
has a different name to it.
It's called distance
vector routing.
And these are the two routing
protocols we're going to study.
Almost all routing
protocols in practice
are variants of either
a vector protocol or one
of these link-state protocols.
There's lots of variance.
And there's hundreds
of routing protocols,
but these cover
the main concepts.
So let me tell you how
distance vector protocols
or how these vector
protocols work.
They're a little different
from the kind of approach
you were going after in
solving this problem.
Had you gone after an
approach where you started
at the destination, at 40--
and 40 simply said, I'm 40.
And then the neighbors next to
40 then said, I'm connected 40.
To get to 40, come through me.
And the cost is, let's
say, whatever the cost
of their link to 40 is, right?
Then, now, initially, nodes
only knew about themselves.
But, now, you have
a destination.
And you have a
set of nodes going
to get to the destination.
Let's call these nodes--
let's just say n1, n2, and n3.
Initially, the only thing
that D says is I am D.
And it says that to its
neighbors along these links.
This saying has a name to it.
It's an advertisement.
Now, when anyone hears
about destination D,
it can do the same
thing to its neighbors.
So let's say these
are n4 and n5 here.
What n1 can do is to
say that, to get to D,
let's imagine that
this cost here is 6.
So D says, I'm D. And
the cost to get to me
is 0 because I'm D.
n1 here's that.
And it says, I'm n1.
That's true.
But to get to D, come
through me and the cost is 6.
So it now puts
out advertisements
along these links.
But it says, D:6, D:6, D:6,
where 6 is the cost of that
link.
Now, let's imagine that
these other links have cost.
So let's say this
link has a cost of 8.
This link has a cost of 2.
Let's say this link
has a cost of 9.
Sorry, I should
draw this better.
Let's put a 9 here.
So the link cost is 8.
The link cost is 9.
And the link cost is 2.
And let's say for a minute here
that this cost of this link
is 10.
Now, n1 advertises to
everybody saying, to get to D,
the cost is 6.
To get to D, the cost to 6.
And to get to D, the cost of 6.
Each of those guys, when
they get this information,
now know that they can get
a route to destination D.
Because now n4 knows that, if
it used this link to get to D,
the cost would be 6 plus
the cost of that link.
So it's 14.
So it would have a routing table
entry that says D is cost 14.
And of course, its
routing table entry
would have an entry saying this
is the link that it should use.
Similarly, n5 here
would take destination D
and say that the
cost to destination D
is 9 plus the
advertisement, which was 6.
And so it would say D is 15.
And n2, which previously
had it a route to D, which
was this link at cost 10, would
look at this new advertisement
coming in here saying that
the cost on this from n1 is 6.
Add that cost to the cost
of the link, which is 2,
and have now a different way
to get to D whose cost is 8.
And compare that
cost against the cost
it previously held
to destination D.
And because we're interested
in minimum cost routing,
8 is smaller than 10.
So n2, which previously had a
cost to destination D of 10,
would throw that route out
and replace it with a route
to destination D
going along this link
with the cost of, now, 8,
which is smaller than 10.
And this process just continues
through as it goes along.
So you might end up in a
situation quite easily, as we
just went through here,
where, let's say, n3
were connected to n5.
If this link had a
cost of 1 and this link
had a cost of 4,
what would eventually
happen is that n5, which
ended up with a cost of 15
to go like that,
would, when it hears
an advertisement from
this node, replace
that route with a cost of 4
and use this link as its route
to get to destination D. And
this process just continues
until everybody has
initially some route to D.
And then if the process
continues a little bit longer,
everybody will have a
minimum cost route to D.
This step, where nodes
evaluate an advertisement
that they hear
about a destination
against their current
route and the current cost
to the destination,
and replace it
if they end up finding
a route with smaller
cost or an advertisement
with smaller cost, when
the cost you have to compare is
the cost of the advertisement
plus the cost of the link along
which that advertisement came
and you compare that
cost against the cost
of the route you already
hold, if it's smaller,
you replace it.
That algorithm is called the
Bellman-Ford for algorithm.
And you might have seen
centralized implementations
of shortest path routing
using this algorithm.
And if you have, it
actually turns out
it's a little less efficient
than another algorithm,
another one we'll the
study called Dijkstra,
if you're doing it centralized.
But it's very, very elegant
elegant for distributed
computation because the routes
to different destinations
are being computed in a
completely distributed way.
These nodes far away
here have no idea
what the network
topology looks like.
They couldn't even reconstruct
the network topology.
The best they could do
is to find their own way
to get their linked to use.
The only information
they have is what
they hear from their neighbors.
But, yet, they're
able to find an answer
because all they have
to do is to listen
to all their neighbors and,
among the set of neighbors,
pick that neighbor
who's advertised
cost plus the cost of
the link to that neighbor
is minimum across
all of the neighbors.
So the computation
that's being done
is a very simple computation.
It's a very elegant
computation, which
is the min over all of the
neighbors of the link cost LIJ
plus the advertised cost from J
where the minimum is done over
that all J, where J is
the set of neighbors of I.
So you minimize over the
set of the neighbors.
Each node I does this.
You minimize over the
set of neighbors J of I.
The link cost from I to J
plus the advertised cost
to destination D of J.
And you take the minimum cost.
That's the minimum cost.
And then you take the link
corresponding to that neighbor.
And that's the
route that you use.
Now, this algorithm gets
more complicated and tricky
to argue that it's correct
when there are failures.
But today, there
are no failures.
There's another wrinkle
in the algorithm, which
is I mentioned that what are the
conditions under which a node
changes its route
to a destination.
So I went through one rule.
I mentioned a rule that
said, if the current route
to the destination does
not exist, in which case
the cost is assumed
to be infinity,
or if the current cost
to the destination
is smaller than the cost of
the advertisement plus the cost
of the link along which
the advertisement came,
then you replace the
route to the destination.
But there's actually
one other condition
under which you should replace
that route to the destination.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
HARI BALAKRISHNAN:
If it's equal, well,
technically, you don't
have to replace it.
You still have a
good path, right?
You could replace it,
but it doesn't matter.
There might be a
case where you have
to replace the link,
the route, when
in fact the cost increases.
There might be a case where
you have a current cost
to the destination
and some current route
to the destination.
And you hear an
advertisement, and you
take that advertisement.
And you add the link cost,
and you find a bigger number.
And you might sometimes
have to replace it.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
HARI BALAKRISHNAN: Right.
It could be that what's going
on here is that the cost
to the destination, a link--
I previously told you that my
cost to the destination is 17.
And, now, I've changed my mind.
I tell you that
it's actually 19.
And I could change my mind
for a variety of reasons
usually having to
do with failure.
So I guess this is a little
bit of a cheating question
because I told you
there's no failures.
But it could be that
perhaps the cost of a link
changed because it became
more expensive or something
like that.
And that's the only
sort of case you
have to worry about where
a cost of the advertisement
could increase.
And if that cost increases
along your current route,
like you think that the route
to the destination is 17,
the cost is 17, but in
fact, it turns out to be 24.
That's the time when you
have to change your entry
in the routing table.
You have to change the
cost associated with it.
But, otherwise, it's basically
that's the algorithm.
And it's summarized
over in this chart here.
And I've gone through
pretty much all of it.
Does anyone have any questions?
No questions?
How long does it take before
every node in the network--
actually, before I get
to that, the reason
it's called a
vector protocol is I
showed you a picture
for one destination.
But in fact, each
switch or each node
does it for all destinations.
So the general form of a
distance vector advertisement
looks like this.
It has a destination,
destination 1 colon cost 1,
destination 2 colon cost 2,
destination 3 colon cost 3,
and so forth for
all the destinations
to which you have a cost.
And initially when
you start, you
don't know about any
of the other nodes.
If you have a route to some
destination in general,
then there's some cost
associated with it.
If you know about a destination
but have no route to it,
the cost is infinity.
It'll turn out next week we'll
find that the value of infinity
in this network has
to be pretty small,
but that's because
this algorithm is not
the world's best algorithm
for big networks.
And I'll explain why infinity
has to be a small number,
but theoretically we can
assume it's infinite.
The reason it's called
a vector protocol
is because the advertisements
are a vector of destination
cost tuples.
And so you send
these tuples around.
And this is a vector
of these tuples.
And, hence, this is
called a vector protocol.
It really should be called
cost vector protocol.
But initially, they ran this
thing where all of the links
had cost of 1.
And, therefore, they
were minimizing distance.
And the name stuck.
But if we wanted to
be perfectly precise,
we would say cost vector.
But then no one
else in the world
would understand what you meant.
So we say distance vector.
OK, any questions?
All right, for some
destination, how long
does it take before
every node in the network
has a route to that destination?
By how long, I mean, how
many advertisement cycles
do you have to go through?
How many of these
advertisements?
Let's say that the way
our world is going to work
is initially every
node advertises
its own advertisement to itself.
Then at the next
time step, every node
advertises the routes
that it knows about.
And then it does
that periodically.
So let's say that, every t
seconds, a node sends out
an advertisement where an
advertisement basically
contains this vector of tuples
for all of the destination
it knows about, right?
So let me explain
this protocol again,
and then I'll ask
you the question.
The protocol is very simple.
Every t seconds, what
the node is doing
is looking at two columns
in its routing table.
It's looking at the destination
column and the cost column.
And it's just taking
that information out.
And it sends out
an advertisement,
the distance vector
advertisement, every t seconds.
How long does it take?
Now, let's focus on one
destination D, some destination
D in the network.
And you have some network.
How long does it take
before every node has
some route to the destination?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] up to
the number of [INAUDIBLE]..
HARI BALAKRISHNAN: Up to the
number of edges in my network?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, because
if you're [INAUDIBLE]..
HARI BALAKRISHNAN: All right.
So let's say you have a
network that looks like this.
How long does it take
before every node
has a route to destination D?
AUDIENCE: So in that
case, it only takes one--
HARI BALAKRISHNAN: Therefore--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] worst
case everything is in a line.
HARI BALAKRISHNAN:
Well, I'm asking
for an answer that holds
for all networks, not for--
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
What do you call the worst
case, like how fast [INAUDIBLE]..
HARI BALAKRISHNAN:
Sure, in the worst case,
it could-- well, yes.
In the absolute worst
case, it is true
that it'll always take time
smaller than the number
of edges in the network.
But you can come up with
a much better bound.
So let's try to
come up-- yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: What if you did the
number of nodes [INAUDIBLE]
longest length chain?
HARI BALAKRISHNAN:
Longest length chain,
so that's not completely true.
Longest, what kind
of longest length?
So another counter
example, let's
say that I have this network.
The longest length chain
is 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
But, yet, you guys just
told me that, in one shot,
you get the answer.
So you have to clarify what
you meant a little bit.
You're almost right.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: In this cast, it
might actually be 6, right?
Because you want to find
that path of the top one
and the bottom one?
HARI BALAKRISHNAN:
I said find a path
or find a route,
not the best route.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
HARI BALAKRISHNAN:
How long does it take
to find a route in a network?
You said this almost.
The longest path-- but it's
not quite the longest path.
It's the longest something path.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
HARI BALAKRISHNAN: The
longest shortest path,
that is the the
longest path when
you compute the
longest over all paths
with a minimum number of hops
between one place to another.
That's also called the
diameter of the network.
OK?
Yes?
OK.
All right, now, that's the time
it takes a multiplied by t.
And I might be off by 1.
You know, it's that minus 1.
Actually, it's not.
It is the number of hops along
the longest shortest path.
Now, how long does it take
to find the minimum cost
path to some destination
D at all of the nodes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
HARI BALAKRISHNAN: What?
HARI BALAKRISHNAN:
t times-- no, that's
true that you can
find it within that.
That's too long.
So I'm going to come
back to this question.
It's probably answered
in chapter 18, I think.
But we've come back
to that next time.
It'll become a
little bit clearer.
But you should think about it.
There's a nice, succinct
answer to this question.
And generally speaking,
in every quiz,
there's some variant
of this question.
So you know, it's not
explicit, but there's
some story that requires--
yes, you have an answer?
AUDIENCE: No, I have a question.
HARI BALAKRISHNAN: Oh, you do.
OK.
I'll come back to that
question next time.
But yes?
AUDIENCE: Can you go
over again what you mean
by the longest shortest path?
HARI BALAKRISHNAN: Yeah,
I can go over that.
So let's say you have D here.
You look at this destination
D. And you look at,
from every node, what's
the path with the smallest
number of hops--
number of hops, not cost--
to get to that
destination, right?
For this guy, it's 1, 2, 3.
For this guy, it's
1, 2, 3, et cetera.
Whatever that biggest number is
multiplied by t is the answer.
That's how long it takes before
every node hears some path.
But it's not quite the right
answer for the best path.
Because as you saw in this
example here, it took us
one step before n2 got a
route to the destination.
But it took us two time steps
before it got its best route
to the destination.
And the reason was
that it has something
to do with the length of the
minimum cost path, right?
Because in this case, the
length of the minimum cost path
is 2 plus 6, 8.
It took 2 hops, which is
different from the length
of some shortest hop
path, which was one hop.
So if I look at this picture,
n2 hears about some route
to the destination in
the first advertisement.
But then to find its best
route to the destination
requires us to
actually wait around
until we find this 2 plus
6 path, which took 2 hops.
So it's a little longer, but
it's not enormously long.
It's just a little bit longer.
And the answer, of
course, depends.
In the worst case, it
could be quite long.
But it depends on
the number of hops
along the minimum cost path.
And if you minimize
that quantity,
you'll find the answer
to the question,
how long does it take
before every node finds
the minimum cost path
to the destination.
OK, is that clear?
Any questions about
distance vector?
Crystal clear?
OK.
We'll see when the
lab comes around.
It is crystal.
Everybody really, really
does well in these labs.
And it's a lot of fun
hacking this stuff up.
So you'll implement
both protocols.
And you'll actually look
at all sorts of failures.
And it'll just be
sometimes miraculous
that it actually works
even when you didn't
consider some failure cases.
OK.
Now, I'm going to talk
about link-state routing.
And this is the routing
protocol that you guys
were sort of attempting
to implement,
attempting to come up with.
This is a radically
different approach
from the vector protocols.
In a vector protocol,
everybody advertises,
for each destination, a
vector of tuples where it's
the destination and the cost.
In a link-state protocol,
we don't do that.
The link-state protocol does not
compute in a distributed way.
In a link-state protocol, every
node just says, I am node 17.
And I'm connected
to 16, 45, and 44.
And the cost of my
link to 16 is 7.
The cost of my link
to 45 is something.
And my cost of my link to this
other neighbor that I have
is something else.
So every node advertises what
I've shown up on this slide.
Every node advertises
a neighbor,
its immediate neighbor, and
the link cost to that neighbor.
OK.
In addition, in each of these
link-state advertisements,
there is a sequence number.
The sequence number starts
at some initial value,
like, say, zero.
And every time one of these
link-state advertisements
is sent-- and that's
done periodically
as well, every t seconds.
Every time you send a
link-state advertisement,
you increment the
sequence number by one.
Now, here's the key step.
The key step here is
that, if I receive
a link-state
advertisement from you,
I just send that
to my neighbors.
And then my neighbors will
send it to their neighbors
and so on.
So it's a very this
nice flooding protocol.
Every node sends out its
link-state advertisement.
And every neighbor that receives
it processes that and then
turns around and ships
it to their neighbors.
And they do the same thing to
their neighbors and so forth.
Now, when this flooding process
completes and every node
is originating its own
link-state advertisement--
so you're telling
them your neighbors
who you're connected to.
She's telling her neighbors
who she's connected to.
And we all do that.
And we're all doing
this in parallel.
It's all happening
at the same time.
And all our neighbors
are rebroadcasting this.
And eventually,
every node is going
to get one or more copies of
every link-state advertisement,
which means that every
node can now construct
an entire map of the network.
Every node can construct
this entire graph.
And once they
construct that graph,
every node can implement some
shortest path routing protocol
to compute the paths
over that graph.
This is very different
from the previous protocol.
In vector routing
protocols, the nodes
actually have no idea what the
topology of the network is.
All they know is they trust
what the neighbors tell them.
Here, under the basic
model, every node
has complete knowledge of
the overall network topology.
So let me show this
by example, and it
will become completely clear.
So let's imagine that this is
what the network looks like.
I'm going to show you a
picture of node F. Node F
originates its initial
link-state advertisement.
And then every advertisement, it
increments the sequence number
by 1.
And it says, I'm connected
to node G with a cost of 8
and to node C with a cost of 2.
And it spits it out
to its neighbors.
Each of those neighbors turns
around and does the same thing.
You rebroadcast a link-state
advertisement along the links
that you are connected to.
And they rebroadcast
it and so forth.
And eventually, B gets it.
And he broadcasts it,
too, though it was
completely useless to do so.
Well, not completely.
If packets are lost,
it's pretty useful.
Anyway, when this
flooding completes,
which takes some
number of steps,
every node now has at least
one-- if no packets are lost,
every node has a
bunch of copies of
this link-state advertisement.
If packets can get lost, as
long as the loss rates are not
enormous, every node
might have one copy
of a link-state advertisement.
And, now, every node
originates its own link-state
advertisement.
And, therefore, they end up
with a map of the network.
By the way, why do we
have the sequence number
in the link-state advertisement?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I don't know, if F
broadcasts its advertisement
and something changes and it
broadcasts a new advertisement,
by the time the two
advertisements get to B,
you don't know which
one gets there first.
So you want to [INAUDIBLE].
HARI BALAKRISHNAN: That
is one of the two reasons
why you have it.
That's actually
the second reason.
And that's a valid reason.
But the main reason
you have it is
that, if C gets a link-state
advertisement originating
from F with sequence number
17, and then eventually C
is also going to
get D rebroadcasting
that link-state advertisement.
Because F sends it this way,
but F also sends it this way.
And that goes up here,
and that comes down here.
And then D rebroadcasts it.
C needs a way of telling whether
this link-state advertisement
is new or old, right?
And the way it tells
if it's new or old
is it considers a
link-state advertisement
to be new if it's bigger
than the last sequence number
it received from that origin.
So, now, every node has
a map of the network.
And, now, we run
this integration step
where we actually take
this map of the network,
and we find shortest
paths to the network.
I need a show of hands.
How many people know
how Dijkstra's algorithm
works from class?
How many people don't
know how it works?
All right, what
I'm going to do is
it's described very
well in the notes.
We'll talk about in
recitation tomorrow,
but I'm going to
show it by example.
And then we'll come back
to this again on Monday.
But I'm going to tell you this
now because you kind of need it
for the lab.
And it is described very
well in the readings.
And we'll do it in
recitation as well.
So here's how it works.
Let's imagine we
want to find paths
from A to all of the other
nodes in the network.
Now, initially, A doesn't
know paths to anyone
except for itself.
But what A knows is
this map of the network.
And what A is trying
to do is to find routes
to all the other destinations.
The way it does that
is it keeps building up
in non-decreasing order of the
cost of the minimum cost back
to the destination.
It starts building up
information about the routes
to the different destinations.
So initially, it
looks at this table.
And it says, it's
connected to C.
And it's to get to
B with a cost of 6.
So what it does is it
says, all right, among all
of the people out
here, I'm going
to pull in the person with
the minimum cost path.
And in this case, it might
just pick the node C.
Because between C
and B, it doesn't
matter which one it picks.
Now, the cost to all
of the other guys
is considered to be infinity.
So it has costs of 6 and 6,
so it pulls in one of them
without loss of generality.
It just picks one of them.
And, now, it has
costs to both of them.
And it says that the route from
A itself, at A, the route to C
is this link.
What it then does
is it goes and looks
at all of the neighbors
connected to A and C.
And in fact, it only has to look
at the new node it pulled in.
And it has to adjust the
cost of the minimum cost path
to the destination
that's connected to that.
In this case, it
adjusts from infinity.
It brings down the
cost to D to 13.
Because it knows that
it can get to C in 6.
6 plus 7 is 13.
Similarly, it does
that for E at 10.
And then it does that to F at 8.
So, now, it has costs of 6,
6-- that 6 is already in--
6, 13, 10, and 8, and infinity.
So, now, it has to decide
what node to pull in next.
And it pulls in the node
with the minimum cost
among the costs that
you have so far.
And that's this node over here.
So it pulls that in
if my wireless works.
There we go.
And then once it pulls that
in, it adjusts the route
to that to be that green link.
And then it goes ahead and
looks at the neighbors of B.
And it adjusts the
shortest path cost.
In this case, that
13 now becomes 11
because 6 plus 5 going through
B is shorter than 6 plus 7
going through C.
And, now, it repeats.
It pulls down the minimum.
The minimum, in this case, is 8.
It pulls in F, makes
that be the route to F.
Now, the route to
F is not that link.
The route to F is, in fact,
this link at the routing table.
But it knows that because it
knows that F is connected to C.
And, therefore,
the route to F is
equal to the route to the
parent, which is C. Therefore,
in its routing table
entry, it makes the route
to F be that link, which
is exactly the link to C.
So that's the subtlety you
have to keep in mind when
you implement this
stuff in the lab.
It goes ahead and
adjusts that to 16.
It now pulls the minimum,
which will be 10,
and then adjusts the cost
of the guys connected to it.
So D changes to 10.
And then it now goes ahead
and pulls the minimum in.
In this case, it's D
with the cost of 10.
That's the link to use.
And that link,
therefore, the route to D
is the same as the route
to E. The route to E
to C, which is that link.
And, now, you finally
conclude the algorithm
by getting that last node in.
So I'm going to stop here.
That was Dijkstra's algorithm
and the two routing protocols.
We'll pick it up in
recitation tomorrow.